outside  wow what has happened here plus 10.  um I guess it's about the black key  remember the black king I'm doing a  quick count it's level material and it  must just be a checkmating idea  um I guess you can also go and grab  Black's Rook the White Knight is  actually very well placed it can grab  the black Bishop the black Rook  um so it might be a material advantage  as well but this move uh I felt going  for that black king and also it's deadly  yeah very quickly just the tournament  scores at the moment I mean the top  eight players I think it's important to  say out of 16 they go through to the  next stage there's only tomorrow left  and hands I think is in ninth position  so this win would put him in  qualification and is this the end that  check looks horrible is it already going  yeah resigns  crushed him wow didn't even get a chance  wow 21 moves this only lasted 11 minutes  Hans Neiman takes three